wait there's a new chapters at the
tell-tale walking dead game the holy
five dollars well-spent Batman let's
jump on this [ __ ] The Walking Dead 400
days that's right kind of sounds like a
romantic comedy but it's not but there
are enough things in this game that will
rip out need a man's heart so it works
so The Walking Dead 400 days ultimately
serves as a bridge between the first
season of The Walking Dead game and the
second season of The Walking Dead game
that did the games done by Telltale
Games you know the good Walking Dead
games I was like new chapter of the game
it was the kick-ass game of 2012 let's
do that and this might have spoilers to
the Walking Dead game by Telltale Games
so if you haven't played it be warned
and in The Walking Dead 400 days it is
one chapter it's about as long as one
chapter of the previous game loves and
it's a few different unrelated stories
that ultimately converge at the end but
for the most part they're unrelated
stories you can play these stories in
any given order you want and it's more
of what you loved about the walking day
- lien Clementine sorry and this is
brilliant it's so smart because it does
a few things for us one it gets us
jacked up for another Walking Dead game
right there that is good news and I am
I'm jacked up for it I can't wait for
the next Walking Dead game and - it
shows us that we can have a Walking Dead
game that doesn't rely on the Lee and
Clementine relationship and still have
it kick ass that was my fear for the
next season of The Walking Dead when I
say season in this video I mean the
Walking Dead game by Telltale Games not
the show I know I was like a no duh
moment but you would be surprised I was
like how can they have a Walking Dead
game and have it be good without the
relationship between Lee and Clementine
luckily apparently it works because they
are nowhere in this game in this game is
awesome or this is one chapter of a game
oh it's actually a bridge between two
games and when I say it's more of what
you loved it's more of what you love you
have new characters that's always cool
you have those life-and-death choices
that you have to make does that person
live does that person live do they die
with what to do I love that about the
last Walking Dead game and that's so
cool that I got more fat in new content
one thing I can say is in terms of the
characters you don't get as attached to
the characters as you did in the last
Walking Dead game and I'm not talking
about lean Clementine I'm saying the
characters in general in the last one
your relationship and interaction with
everyone grew over the span of a few
chapters some died before some others
did but for the most part you got to
build rapport with people
this one isn't only one chapter the
characters are in this
after for about one-fifth of the chapter
so it's literally like a bunch of short
stories if the last Walking Dead Season
was like a novel this one is the novella
with short stories in it really like
okay great short stories but it doesn't
have that character development the
scope of the entire game doesn't feel as
big because you're just not with the
characters or the situations or the
timeline for Islam but in that they do
make the best of the situation they give
you what you want you don't have to wait
as long to get it I will say this 400
days did feel a bit darker than the
first season of The Walking Dead did I
know that's a lot but I'm just saying in
a lot of these stories when the story
ended and I was going on to the next one
I was just lying people died I feel like
they died because of me did I make the
right decision I don't know if I did or
not but that's the fun of these Walking
Dead games ultimately I loved all of the
chapters in this game I liked a lot of
the characters there was some supporting
characters I thought were dick bags it
does everything really well like they
did in the first season the writing in
this game you're like yep this is the
crew that gave me the telltale Walking
Dead game and this is why I loved it
when they want to make a character
creepy or uncomfortable that character
is uncomfortable thing I will remember
most about this is that one character I
was like I don't like you and I just
don't want to be around you he's that
uncomfortable character that I know
you've thought about whenever you
thought about all right if the
apocalypse happens and I run across that
person I'm either leaving completely or
killing him one of those creep bags is
in this episode I thought that was
awesome because I will remember that
dude in that situation I just didn't
like him I didn't like him in the way
I'm supposed to not like him which means
it was effective it's not like he was a
stupid character that shouldn't be in
the game if you were a fan of the
telltale games Walking Dead game this is
a necessity dropped 5 bucks right now
and buy it it's more of what you loved
about the first one it's your holdover
until season 2 happens they didn't feel
like they were phoning it in for the
sake of shutting us all up you know
because we wanted to play more Walking
Dead since we beat the first one they
were like here we really tried to give
you something good here's our effort I
didn't even want to write this one out
because I'm like well buy it at full
price is five bucks what's that say
about the game it ultimately being DLC
that's bridging the gap between two
gaming experiences I feel like being
awesome tacular is giving it too much
because I'm like I mean it's not that
long it's five dollar DLC but in terms
of deal seats some of the best five
dollar DLC I've seen have you bought it
yet why haven't you bought it yet this
got me jacked for season two I can't
wait for season two I'm glad that I no
longer I'm thinking about season two
gonna be as good without Lee and
Clementine not saying clementines not
going to be in it I'm just saying
and luckily know if season two how
all new characters I am now completely
looking forward to it so the walking
dead four hundred days have you played
it and what did you think about it if
you haven't played the walking dead by
Telltale Games at all
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]